thank you uh
i jud's probably like my favorite person
in the whole world so uh that was nice
uh anyways this looks like it works uh
unicode uh poop uh there's a
html entity for that as well
uh
just good info to have i think that's
the last actual poop i have in here so
hopefully that helps settle your
stomachs a bit
let's get going if we can there we go
so i had a friend say this to me once
i don't want all those fancy features i
just want a program that eats sass and
poop css
uh
and and that's really the the thing
uh that the the pooping is is about and
uh i'm gonna go ahead and extend the
metaphor for you uh into the css
preprocessor digestive tract
um and hopefully that won't get too
boring uh but but i'll try to stick to
mostly css um
so we uh
we often have information like this this
is a very small style sheet we have some
variables some are
pixels some are colors and we mix them
in and we run functions on them
uh it's nice so so how do we process
that what happens uh whenever we want
css out the other end
so how does eating this
make sass poop this
uh so
preprocessors as they relate to the
digestive system eating is probably
standard in uh
i'd say chewing is is most like lexing
i'll talk about what elixir is but that
kind of breaks up the input into more
easily digestible pieces
uh stomachs are an important part of
of actual digestion systems so i
couldn't really leave them out but they
don't actually the metaphor is very
broken so uh i just added them in here
as some sort of data store that you're
using because that's really all it's
doing maybe uh additional lexing
uh
so your small intestines are kind of
like the the parser step so the parser
step is uh taking out the uh
pieces that you need and putting them in
the right places so this would like be
actually getting nutrients and and
moving it to uh nice uh
parts of your body breaking things down
uh would not be part of that even though
that's something that the small
intestines do so just ignore that uh
large intestines that are similar uh
we'll call that the compiler uh it
really uh
gets it ready for output uh that's
that's where uh
our
i i'm just gonna say output but i think
you know uh and you all know what
standard out is and uh so we're good
there
um
and
i'm gonna talk a little bit about
hacking this system uh and so i just had
to have the metaphor for that so one way
you could hack your digestive tract is
like lap band surgery where they like
make your stomach smaller and then you
have less memory and so maybe your
output is slower or you lose weight or
one of the two
so parsing and compiling is really what
i'd like to talk to you about
rather than the digestive tract
so parsing is is actually pretty easy uh
on a high level it uh uses syntax rules
of the language um and it figures out
what every little part of a string is um
and it breaks them down into tokens so
in this case you have the dollar sign
which in sas means that it's the start
of a variable and then you have the name
of the variable which is blue in this
case you have the equality operator
css uses the colon to
mean equals
and so that's what sas uses
and then you have the value
it could be any arbitrary string usually
there are rules about what can go there
you can't have unicode characters though
like if it was in a url or something it
might work probably just about anything
there except for a semicolon
and then you have a rule delimiter to
say hey this is the end of the rule
and so that's pretty easy you might be
able to write a regex to to go through
and and break apart those things you're
really looking for three things in that
case uh and filling in the gaps uh
you see the dollar sign is a variable
and then you fill in the gaps until you
get to a colon and you fill in the gaps
then you get to a semicolon and so
that's really at the very base of how
you set a variable how a computer breaks
that stuff down
more specifically it goes through every
single character
and it says is this part of anything
that i might know about and it has a few
options and if there's only one option
then it says oh this must be the dollar
sign to to mean a variable but if two
things could start with a dollar sign it
might look ahead and do other things
there's lots of ways to write parsers
that i don't even know about uh here is
my most simple example of how you might
write this parser in javascript uh which
sas is not written in the the most uh
uh
non-congruent part of my talk is that
all of my examples is
are in sas and all of my code is in
javascript
so you'll just have to deal with that
mental
trust point
anyways uh we essentially just loop
through a string uh we we get a string
in uh as css uh it's just it's just text
it's uh you have characters in there uh
and in this case we're just saying if uh
we loop through and the character is a
semicolon we know there's a semicolon
and so we have a list of of tokens
and then we push the semicolon token uh
in this case it's just the string
semicolon which probably
might be okay for semicolon but you'd
probably need more info like the
variable is is this type of variable all
kinds of stuff this is a very simplified
example so you'd want one of those
things where
you're noticing a semicolon for every
possible thing in the language unless
it's dynamic and then you use other
techniques for those
more realistically you probably write a
parser generator
some people might disagree with me on
this but but most of the time
when you need a quick parser for
something
you can actually use something like peg
that's a parser expression
grammar generator
and you can generate a parser based on
expressions and so you say that
a class is actually just a dot followed
by an identifier
and then you kind of say like whenever i
build this up say an element
is just an identifier or the
the asterisk for everything and
identifiers can be
anything with dashes or numbers or
characters and all kinds of stuff you
don't necessarily have to understand the
syntax or more or less anything here
other than that
you can
kind of
build up a language and then someone
will actually just generate a very fast
parser for you and you don't have to
worry about
this type of stuff
unless you want to make it very very
fast in which case you do this by hand
and see
which libsas things like that that's how
those work
so when you're done you need to
represent the code as data it comes in
as text it comes in as an array of
characters
uh so
this uh is text and you eventually after
lexing uh have this you have the
variable starting you have the string
you know the value of the string you
know that the next thing is equals and
that the value of the
everything so you have that
and you want to actually add structure
so you
take the variable set you know that this
needs to end
with the semicolon you say actually the
way
setting variables works is it has two
sides and so you're going to build an
arbitrary object that says the left side
is the variable name and it's blue and
the right side is the value
and it's 3bb fce
i don't know where that value jed had
all the switching names this morning
pro tip that was a good move uh styles
have structure so even further you might
have a the stylesheet object that wraps
that whole thing so if your your whole
style sheet was just one variable
declaration it might look kind of like
this you'd have you'd have an object
that said my type is a style sheet and
in it it has declarations
and the first one is a variable that's
set in a certain way and the second one
is a declaration the selector is uh
the stuff class inside p tags and the
rules are left color val
the color of fff so we're just saying
stuff p stuff has the color of white
and that actually
might look more like this in sas
so you have bodies and you have a tags
and they're nested
inside uh
the hover states are nested inside so
you actually have uh what what ends up
looking like this whenever you actually
break it down i can make this smaller
for you
maybe i can't there we go
closer
uh
so we end up with a hierarchy we have a
style sheet
and we know that we have a body rule and
we have an a rule and inside of those we
have rules and inside of those we have
rules and with with sas you can nest
infinitely uh i think
uh
nicole once said that uh you should
follow the inception rule and never go
more than four levels deep
uh which i like that is that is good uh
but technically you have the ability to
go as deep as you'd like in normal css
uh you can only have one level but it's
still a tree it's just uh uh
not that
tall of one
uh anyways this is an abstract syntax
tree that's what i've been uh describing
uh it's confusing because there are
almost no rules uh if anyone asks an
abstech an abstract syntax tree is just
a list of things that contain uh one
thing or other lists of things
i like to call them arbitrary syntax
trees
um
they almost don't mean anything
uh so they're they're actually they've
got such a cool name that you want to
derive more value out of that name but
really all it is is a representation of
the
meaning of your syntax
in a structure so in the case of css we
don't want just uh there was a variable
then this and then a semicolon and then
this like there's no actual structure
that means anything we want to be able
to say that this is a group that
contains rules that contain groups that
contain rules and we know that the
things inside of a group apply to only
its outer
selectors
so what can we do with it
lots of stuff and that's why it's fun
so
i'll go into what we can do with it in a
second but the compilation step is the
first thing you would normally do with
it compile it to css
so reduction
is the first step
whenever you're dealing with something
like compiling sas into css you have
scss which we've been using here and
it's kind of like a superset
of css
most of the things are very similar and
so we want to take the data
from the scss that looks kind of like
this we have a variable that we're
setting uh to blue so we're saying blue
is that three bb
uh number and then we have a rule that
uses the variable
and that's not valid css uh at least
until css level four not css4
css unversioned level four
uh
totally different guys come on
um
the uh
uh yeah so so this is not valid css we
couldn't compile this we couldn't turn
this back into a string and have this
actually work in any browser
what we want to do is reduce the
variables away so in this case we'd say
find any place that has the value where
the type is a variable and the name is
blue
and that'd be pretty easy and then just
replace it with the value of the blue
variable and you might be able to do
that in your head very easily
it's somewhat complicated in code but we
won't actually have to do that and so
you end up with this and this ends up
being actually a completely valid css
syntax tree we just have a rule and uh
the name is the color and the value is a
legit color
and we can just compile that single rule
into css and there's no problem and
that's valid uh 100
valid css you could even use the sas uh
lecture backwards not that lectures
worked that way but because scss works
that way you could turn it back into
what the sas the scss representation of
this would be
and would be completely valid css in
this case
and what you would do
is just do that on the most specific
node and then you'd go up and you do
that on those nodes and then you go up
and you go up
and
you compile
so
i lost too much recursion uh everybody's
friend so uh your reduction comes from
this and you're able to output this
uh and you do that recursively leaves to
trunk and i say leaves a trunk because
uh they're like uh there's a split
somewhere in the middle of the room of
people who say that that's up the tree
and there are people who say that that's
down the tree and i think it's probably
down the tree
but because you're going leaves to trunk
uh
but whenever you represent a syntax you
actually draw it upside down uh and so
it's actually more like stalag tights uh
or something and we should just change
uh abstract syntax stalactites
uh from now now on if you would uh uh
arbitrary syntax stalactites
would work for me
um anyways
so we take something that looks like
this we put it into the structured data
you don't actually have to read that but
this is you know some arbitrary way of
saying there are declarations with rules
inside of them and we know what they all
mean
and it's just big and ugly
and we reduce that to something that is
valid for css and you have to know
what's going on here but we no longer
have variables in there we no longer
have nested structures it's all a valid
tree and then we're able to just turn
that back into text again
so it takes one type of text
converts it into a known but arbitrary
data format and then it converts that
data into a different but arbitrary and
known data format
and it converts that back to text so
that was like a very long drawn out way
of saying that it takes text turns it
into data
fiddles with it
and then turns it back into text
so there's a very sophisticated graph on
seeing that
more apropos to the title
we have our digestion system
i threw in some
some
buzzwords
streams i don't know what that that
would be
i guess you pipe saliva
into
standard in uh anyways uh this is this
is really just a
silly metaphor the the only hard part is
actually there in the middle we're
pretty good at uh parsing you can use
parser expression generators we're
pretty good at uh at even knowing how to
define languages as context-free
grammars uh or or
regular uh languages there's this whole
automata theory on all that stuff so
we're pretty good at taking text and
turning it into data and we're pretty
good at turning data and putting into
text it's just the reverse
so
the the magic of sas actually
you know other than some speed things uh
lives in in the data one today to do
data to conversion
um
and
uh it's it's interesting how uh they do
some of that stuff that's not really the
point
uh so i want to teach you what you can
do with it
uh data one can be interesting just
reading the data
can be
pretty eye opening
so data one would be that data that once
we turned it into a structure that
represented our sas
what could we what information could we
get from it
we could count how often we use
variables or we could change them before
they ever get used we could move rules
around we could reduce things we could
lint
we could change
uh the output formats we could output to
multiple formats there's a lot of work
you can do by having your styles as data
and it's super cool to me
so as long as your data is valid at all
points it doesn't matter you can send it
back in so you could take in text turn
into data throw that data away create
your own whole new data and then compile
that to css and that's fine just
wouldn't have any bearing on what you
put in
uh
and that's that's an okay thing i guess
sometimes
so i wrote this uh very uh important uh
modifier of rules and so you would pass
this in as a filter
to your ast so your data comes in
and what it does it says
find me all the rules so you don't want
to find the selectors you don't want to
find variable names all you want to say
is anywhere where there's a rule
that has a value let's check that out so
we'll say if it has a value
say the value plus important so
we save every value as important and
then write it back to the tree
and then recursively do that so we call
ourselves uh over and over so we go all
the way down and hit every single rule
in our entire css file and then just
return all that
and then we compile that and now every
single one of our rules is important
in the output and you didn't have to
write those by hand so this will save
you a lot of time doing what you are
going to do anyways
which was probably just that important
to everything
luckily we can do the reverse
the undo intern work
ast modification tool
so we go through every single node we
find if it's a rule we say if it matches
important return null so delete the rule
entirely
don't turn it unimportant just say if
this is important
then it should die forever
which is another valid opinion to have
outputs may vary
uh and that that type of logic works in
every preprocessor obviously that code
will not work in every preprocessor
everyone has different ways of storing
nodes and values and things like that
rework is won by uh tj vision media who
who has five or six hundred modules
on github
but it is made
specifically for ast hacking
he actually ships it with no features
it literally just takes stuff in turns
into data and then turns that data back
into css
and then it's up to you to stick stuff
in the middle so you might be familiar
with the term middleware so you write a
bunch of little middleware pieces
that uh
change nodes around and you say if i
want to add variables i just add one
little piece this is variables and
that's the only thing i want to use in
my preprocessor so i'm not going to add
in nesting and i'm not going to add in
gradients or or uh
uh variable um
what are the preventer prefixes all that
kind of stuff you don't need them so
don't add them in or you could do
totally custom stuff so a little more
real world a problem that i actually
ran into in my day-to-day work
is that compilation of styles is fast
you can take
a sas style sheet or a stylus in the
case that i that i originally had and
you can compile styles pretty quickly so
it's rarely at the bottleneck in
anyone's build step
they can get slow uh some people will
move to libsas for that kind of thing
uh the asterisk there is until you want
to hook it up to a change event
so if you hooked up the color picker to
a change event and said on change you
know 60 times a second or whatever that
can do
go back to the server recompile all my
styles with the new value and set this
variable just to this this new value
that i have on the change thing and then
send all that back up delete all the
styles and put all the new ones in
that would never work
and luckily
now that you know about asts you could
fix that problem
so uh in something like a theme builder
you would want a size slider or color
picker to do all this stuff in real time
so the only way we can avoid the time it
takes to recompile is to not recompile
uh and luckily we can capture that data
at the data level uh and use that to our
advantage um and still only ever write
uh the sas or the stylus for the this
the rework that we want uh to write so
i'll open up
a demo for you
this is a fun little page uh it's got a
pun uh for for jed uh leaf uh and tree
uh just to point that out for
everyone um thank you
so what we have here is a pretty simple
page uh i put it together it's an
express app uh it's uh if you saw the
first slide i had a link to it but you
can get it'll be on the left side too
and you can run it from from github
uh so what we have first is i'll pull up
a
my css
my css is my
personal uh
compiler for for css all i did was add
variables i use rework to do this
and so i add this one little guy here
that says var
and then i pass it a variable name and
then
in in the compilation step it adds in my
actual variables which i uh
put uh in in my server i don't know why
i did that but that's where it is so i
take these and i i essentially replace
those so i wrote a
a
middleware component to rework that just
goes in and replaces those variables
with the actual values and that's pretty
simple and so
if you come here i can show you the
output and you'll see that there are
actual background colors
and there are actual widths um and
and all this kind of stuff so it's real
it happens
and it's fun
and it works and yeah so some things
that uh devtools is really good at is is
saying hey i know uh where this rule is
working on my page i can go uh and say i
can right click on something and say
what styles apply to this element but
you don't actually have a lot of insight
into
how your sas variables map up to things
on pages you don't have that it's
compiled to css before it ever gets to
the browser so we have that information
and so what i also did was i grabbed the
ast stage and i flipped the ast on its
head
so you can take your variables and you
can say which selectors do they apply to
and which rules
work on those selectors based on that
variable so you might say if bg color
ends up being black
then you would say it would output in
the end output that the body html
bracket background color colon black
close bracket right and that would be
the rule that's generated from a black
bg color
and we have this data available to us as
json and if i change anything in our css
file this automatically just gets
changed it's not something i have to
maintain
separately it's just completely
generated from the ast uh of our stuff
and so i have a few things here it says
uh 2 next to bg color and i can hover
over and it says the bg color of the
html element which is the total wrapping
element the body which has a margin on
it uh comes down to to where the the
margin is
and then the
font color of leaf them alone is the
same as the background color
and so we see that we actually have uh
two rules where it's used it shows up
three times on the page and we can
actually position something over every
time we see this variable we can also
come in here grab a color picker
and change these in real time so we can
have you know 60 frames per second
recompilation of styles
because we know exactly which elements
are affected by this we don't have to go
back to the server recompile you'll
notice the the text is changing at the
same time as uh as the background there
uh we can actually just pop into here
and and check i just inject a style
element with just that rule in it
uh and that rule says uh the body and
the container subheader now have this
new color and it just overrides our
current styles
and so that's pretty nifty and uh
that's information you could never get
from devtools until they have deeper
integrations with this stuff you can
also do fun stuff with border radius i
like this is this trippy right here
ready for this
oh there's css for you
this is my favorite one
i just
that's gonna translate well on the slide
deck
uh anyways
that's uh actually just about all i have
um
does anyone have questions
you